ladies and gentlemen the armed conflict
in Yemen is escalating more and more
with each passing day for three weeks
airstrikes have been carried out there
by the saudi-led military coalition in
other words Yemen is besides the civil
war in a state of international war in a
statement for March 27 enesco Director
General in our ena Bokova urged all
parties involved in military operation
to preserved the Yemeni culture heritage
but how to protect culture heritage in
Yemen I Qaeda Houthi rebels growing
islamization and increasing radicalism a
failed state a threat to the west these
are the headlines we meet when reading
about Yemen today so protection of
culture heritage in Yemen is getting
more and more difficult if not even
impossible also the German ecology
institute with its browns and sana since
1978 conducted field research the last
time in spring 2011 whereas other
project like capacity building measures
for the general organization of
Antiquities and Museum proudly called go
on had to be stopped in Yemen and of
2013 Yemen the ancient South Arabia the
land of the Queen of Sheba and the
former arabia felix happy arabia is
among the oldest and most multifaceted
cultural landscape on the Arabian
Peninsula its heritage looks back up in
millennia of years yet in view of the
political unrest there today this
heritage has been forgotten more and
more nezam nevertheless in addition to
human suffering insecurity and loss in
community life this crisis encroaches
upon zacata heritage of Yemen as well
which until now was used
in national dialogue and in the self
identifying representation of the state
however the lack of or no longer
effective mechanism of state control and
the different yemeni provinces have mean
violet to the increasing destruction of
its cultural heritage this destruction
is secured through illicit diggings
plunder unauthorized construction
projects and growing illegal trade in
antiquities for example this is
reflected by an anomalous increasing
number of south or abyan antiquities
offered in auction houses in order to
abuse you illegal trade in culture goods
or germanic logic institute is in close
contact with the yemeni antiquity
authorities and the german federal crime
police office furthermore reports about
systematic illegal excavation have
increased even before the present crisis
these were alarmingly active in regions
in which authority of the central
government had little or no influence
and now they too have increasing with
the spread of anarchy throughout large
areas of the country nevertheless too
far and let us hope that it will remain
so there is no indication of fanatical
religious motivated destruction of
culture artistic work like we saw before
in the panel in Syria or in Iraq this I
quote attacked on the history
eradication of culture by religious
fanatics will hopefully not become a
future model for Yemen the cultural
roots of Yemen are seen still a starting
knot in the Islamic past only but even
earlier in pre-islamic times whether the
Queen of Sheba the great term of Merit
or the rulers of him your empire in the
yemeni highlands who knew to unite the
country and spread the authority over
almost all of present-day yemen during
our many xk
we never experienced rejections or
refusals quite the opposite we met with
much interest and tolerance even marvel
nonetheless the culture heritage of
Yemen and with this i mean the
pre-islamic as well as islamic legacy is
very threatening and stands in acute
danger the yemeni antiquity authorities
and also the general organization of the
preservation of historical cities which
is unfortunately not represented today
by doctor Naji saw a beam as gorham and
gough see which aside from its main
offices in San I have branches in all of
the provinces is responsible among other
duties for pursuing and obstructing
these illegal activities to protect and
preserve the culture heritage and to
impose counteractions impurity for the
successful operation of these measures
is the systematic recording and
documentation following international
guidelines of archaeological sites and
ecological material in collection and
museums as well as objects with tree
from illegal context nevertheless only
few members of the gorram office process
founded knowledge of modern methods for
documenting culture heritage the
president of Goya muhannad aziani is
well aware of this problem and very
engaged in seeking solutions already in
2012 a program for further education was
initiated by the german ecology
institute in sauna due to unstable
conditions the gym and however this
undertaking had to be prematurely
discontinued for this reason the German
ecology institute with the financial aid
of the German Federal Foreign Office
contact summer school let's say for
employees of Guam in Berlin or and
arabian third country with secure
conditions this year parallel to this
further project will be set up is the
most important international guidelines
and measures for handling culture
material whose documentation and digital
archiving will be published online and
in the print version in arabic in a form
of an advisory a handbook of best
practices in handling was culture
heritage basically gorham is well
structured and as far as personals
concerned well thought out the central
office assigned relatively independently
acting directors to every province who
were responsible for the site as well as
a museum located there the range of
duties encompasses the study protection
preservation including restoration and
conservation of ecological sites as well
as a presentation of the movable and
unmovable culture material the number of
employees is relatively large but still
not enough whereby most are concerned
less was illogical work and function
more as guards these guards stem from
the traditional clans and tribes in the
region of society and are chosen for
this position with the permission of the
head of the respective clan and tribe on
one hand herein lies one important
strength of the system though the
feeling of responsibility for local
culture heritage is correspondent he
great yet on the other hand this
traditional tribal structure has the
result that any influence on the part of
the central state authority is more or
less impossible hence the attempt to
nationalize annika logic aside that is
located outside of an urban center
almost never succeeds archaeological
material found within a tribal region
usually remains in that particular
province mostly even in the vicinity of
society in the tribal area an example is
the sarbanes city of serve our province
of markup where one storage serves for
keeping all kinds of the area and is
guarded by tribal members and still it's
intact as I hurt yesterday the
transference of the fines from this
facility to the province capital mereb
located a mere 40 kilometres away is as
unsinkable ascending a few of the fines
to the national museum in sauna for this
reason most provinces disposed over
least one central provincial museum as
well as number of side museums the
situation combined with the absent of a
central program in which sites and fines
are systematically recorded makes an
overview in control of museums holding
and of archaeological sites including
plunder theft and so on wholly
impossible essential now is the creation
of a specific education courses and
advanced projects as well as technical
support for facilities in order to
implement a data recording system that
is as comprehensive as possible
including digital photographic
documentation of possibles redeem in
order to document existing culture
heritage and to identify objects in our
trade and also possible looted goods in
the medium or maybe more long-term
education and the creation of often
unbiased culture historical
understanding in the Yemenis Society for
the history and regional culture
heritage are important elements for its
protection and preservation the German a
kolache Institute together with the
yemeni partners is attempting to
contribute to these efforts in our areas
and this is also an appeal to the
international community not forget to
forget Yemen the former happy Arabia
thank you very much for your attention
and thank you for the organizer